Gwyneth Paltrow has spent plenty of time in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe, but her memories
seem to be a little shaky.
The Academy Award-winning actress, who played
Pepper Potts opposite Robert Downey Jr.'s
Tony Stark across seven Marvel movies, has
admitted that she hasn't seen many of the
Marvel movies she's been in - particularly
2017's Spider-Man: Homecoming.
She spilled the fact to late-night host Jimmy
Kimmel during a recent interview.
Paltrow made waves regarding her small role
in Homecoming - for which she received top
billing, even beating out Zendaya for the
fourth credit - after she infamously argued
with MCU co-star Jon Favreau during the inaugural
episode of his Netflix series The Chef Show
about whether or not she was in the movie.
Paltrow, in fact, seemed a little confused
about the entire situation.
"Thanks for having me!
I mean, thanks for coming!"
But it was undeniably funny when she insisted
that she never appeared in Homecoming, despite
Favreau's assurances that she definitely did.
"You were in Spider-man."
"No."
"Yeah."
"I was in Avengers."
"You were in Spider-man also."
Her confusion makes a degree of sense.
Marvel is famously secretive about the content
of its upcoming films, even altering trailer
footage to throw fans off the scent.
Actors appearing in Marvel Studios films don't
always know the details of the movies they're
in, either.
For example, Brie Larson confessed she didn't
know she was in Avengers: Endgame until she
got to the set.
During her appearance on Jimmy Kimmel Live,
Paltrow confessed that not only does she not
recall appearing in Homecoming, but she also
hasn't ever sat down and watched it.
The reason why?
She she simply got "confused" because, quote,
"There are so many of these wonderful Marvel,
interconnecting movies," and she thought that
her role in the Spider-Man movie was actually
for one of the Avengers films.
"I never actually saw the movie."
"Oh you didn't see the movie?"
"I mean, wait, cut that out!
Take that back!"
In response, Kimmel joked that he doesn't
expect the busy actress to stay up-to-date
on superhero movies, even ones that she's
in.
“You're Gwyneth Paltrow, you shouldn't be
watching Spider-Man.
It would upset people."
Homecoming isn't the only Marvel movie Paltrow
has been in that she's never even seen.
In an interview with Elle, Paltrow revealed
that she's skipped watching a lot of Marvel
films, since the franchise is so big, there
are so many superheroes to keep track of,
and she has other priorities in life.
Her confusion and busy life has led her to
not watch very many Marvel movies, which,
in turn, has made Paltrow totally forget which
MCU films she's starred in.
She told the magazine,
"It is confusing because there are so many
Marvel movies, and to be honest, I haven't
seen very many of them.
It's really stupid and I'm sorry, but I'm
a 47-year-old mother."
This isn't the first time the Marvel star
has appeared confused about the cinematic
universe she's a part of.
She's forgotten Sebastian Stan — aka Bucky
Barnes — multiple times, having asked who
Stan was on a red carpet and getting called
out by Stan himself in an Instagram post after
he introduced himself to her three separate
times.
And Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige previously
spilled that Paltrow was "asking why Sam Jackson
was there" when they were filming a scene
for Avengers: Endgame together.
He recalled,
"The other actors were jumping in saying,
'What are you talking about?
He's Nick Fury!
You've been in movies with him!'"
During the same Kimmel interview in which
Paltrow told the truth about whether or not
she'd bothered to watch Spider-Man: Homecoming,
she was also caught off guard when presented
with products from her lifestyle brand and
online store, Goop, which sells everything
from martini bath salts to a water bottle
that has an amethyst inside of it, for some
inexplicable reason.
Throughout Kimmel's presentation, Paltrow
seems positively puzzled over the vast majority
of the products, leading viewers to wonder
if she's ever looked at Goop's inventory at
all.
"Apparently, it's really from camel.
Are you going to try some?"
It might seem absurd that Paltrow forgets
everything from her acting credits to her
own merchandise, but at the very least, the
star is providing plenty of amusing press
clips for her huge variety of projects - such
a huge variety, in fact, that it seems impossible
for her to remember them all.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.